じゃああの よろしくお願いします
まあこれからあの いわゆる仏教の
まあ論理の世界に皆様まあようこそっていうことですけど
普通の説法と違って あの
いくらか  まあ学問的というか
まあいくらかそういう形で
あの解釈する教えなんです
まあとにかくこの真理学ですね
仏教で言ってる真理学であって
あの まあ真理の解釈っていうことで
まあ物質的なことも扱ってはいるんです
でも真理学の方が あのメインになってるんです
で あの 大体釈尊の教えが
あの我々はダンマと言うんですね
ダンマと言うんです まあよく皆様聞いてらっしゃる言葉なんですけど
ダンマ 教えという意味で法ですね
ですからこの真理として訳するんです
なんで あの真理 教え 法
いろいろな言葉で訳しますかというと
で まず お釈迦様が教えたものですから
教えはダンマという それからお釈迦様は何を教えるんですかというと
まあ真理を教えているんですね
まあ下らない言葉は何も喋らないんですね
釈尊が まあそれはポリシーとして意味のある言葉しか喋らない
一応あの 普通一般的なこの挨拶とか
どうですか 元気ですかとかね
まあそういうことはまあお話はしますけど
普通のまあ予想とかね
まあ家庭の状態はどうですかとかね
それは人間にやっぱり会話しなくちゃいけないことだから
そこら辺は話しますけど
それ以上 まあ意味のないものは喋れない
それは決まってあって
我々にももう気をつけなさいと
いつでも何か意味のある言葉
人々のために ためになる役に立つ言葉を喋りなさいと
そういうことないならば黙っていなさいということは現実ですから
まあそういうことで お釈迦様おっしゃる言葉は全ては真理ですと
真実ですと そういうことで
真理 真実という意味もダンマという言葉に入ってるんです
それに二番 三番目の意味は
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている真理は
これお釈迦様がいてもいなくても
人間がいてもいなくても
世の中の まあ宇宙の存在の在り方なんです
特別な解釈ではないんです
説明ではないんです で
我々はこの科学 いろんな科学分野がありまして
いろんな学問分野がありまして
それは説明なんですね
ある立場で説明する 地理学の立場で何かを説明する
化学の立場で何かを説明する
物理学の立場で何か説明するということになってるんです
で そういうふうなことで
お釈迦様の真理の方は
そういう何かの立場で何か言ってるわけではなくて
世の中の法則 世の中はもう生命と物質の世界はどうやって
どういうふうなものですかと
どういうふうに生滅変化していきますかという
あの普遍的な真理 ですから
この だからダンマというんですね
その場合は この常にある真理
世の中の実際の姿という意味で
三番目の意味でダンマと呼ぶんです
まあそういうことで この単なるパーリ語でダンマといっても
まあ我々はその時その時の意味でそれを理解するんです
釈尊の教えであって それから真理であって
それから普遍的な法則であると
まあそれに不調和しい日本漢字でこの法という法という字与えてますけど
それも結構よく考えて当てている
あの漢字なんです ですから
まあ当時のこういう翻訳した学者の方々は
もう大変この研究して考えて考えてこの字を当ててるんです
ですから この まあそれも
まあそういうことで まあ漢字の言葉も
あのそんなに捨てたものではないんです
問題は我々の今の意味なんですね
今 現代的な漢字の意味と
まあ当時で取った漢字の意味が違ってますから
どうせ違いますからね
で ですからそれはしょうがない
ですから我々はまあ日本語で仏教を読んだってわからないとかね
漢文で読んでもわからないというのは
まあそれ我々現代人にわからないだけで
もし当時の あの意味の漢字の使い方を考えると
なんとかわかる 例えばブッダという場合は
この中国語でホウですから
ホウという どうやって書くんですか？いや
古字はなんかこうかな
こんな感じですね 違うかな
全然書いてないですね
そうですね そういう あの字を書いてあって
それは大体この字の否定形であって
右は それは人間という人間でないという意味で書いてあったそうですね
ですから あの それの説明聞くと僕も驚いたんですね
この右の部分はいろんな意味で使ってるんですね
この左側に入れるものによってね
まあ沸騰する時の同じ字を使ったりするし
ですから水は水でなくなってる瞬間
その時は 自分の状態乗り越えちゃうんですね
その時という場合は その同じ字を書いて
この左側だけ変わっちゃう
そこで人間を入れたところで
やっぱり人間は人間で
人間でもあるんだけど
まあやっぱり違うということで
ですから 仙人の仙人のその字は使ってないんですね
だから仙人というと 山に人偏に山を書いて仙人という言葉ありますけど
それは使ってないんです
だから結構当時ではね
インドの学者やティベットのほうをみんな集めて
グループで考えてディスカッションして漢訳して
それから漢訳したものはまた漢字の人々がまた読み直したりして
まあ大変な仕事でしたからね
まあそれでまあ立派な法という字も
まあ一応意味は入ってるんです
ダンマという意味の じゃあそれはその点で止まってやめて
次に今日から勉強するのはダンマではなくてアビダンマなんですね
それにこの ADHI のこれつけちゃうんですね
ダンマではなくてアビダンマ
アビダンマっていうのは
まあこれなかなか英訳もできないんですが
英訳もないんです だいたい超えているという意味で使ってるんです
で 普通の名詞にアビというこの言葉をつけたら
それはまあ普通の状態よりは優れているという意味になってしまっちゃうんですね
例えば心にチッタというんです
それにアビ入れたら優れてる心になってしまっちゃうんですね
あの慢という言葉 日本語でもありますね
あの高慢の慢 で それはなんで慢というんですかね
パーリ語でマーナと言うんだけど
で まあ余計に似ていますけど
マーナという慢のマーナの代わりにアビ入れたらアビマーナという言葉になってますね
ものすごい高慢 普通の高慢ではなくて
大変な高慢なんですね
その場合は特別な意味で
その高慢というのは 自分が修行して修行してる人々だけの慢なんですね
修行して色々神秘体験やらいろんな体験を得ると
自分が悟ってるんだとか
ものすごく錯覚するんですね
それはなかなかいくら教えたっても解決できないんです
あの 治らがないんです
我々の高慢なんかは まあ何か言うと
それはもう全部まあガタガタ倒れる可能性はありますけど
もし修行して修行して
いろいろ経験があって
それから自分たち自分が大変優れているんだとか
悟ってるんだという風に思ってしまったら
その高慢はもうなかなか解きにくい
大変な怖いものということで
アビマーナと特別な言葉で言ってるんですね
だからそういう説明してたのは
このアビという言葉の意味は
ちょっと普通のレベルよりレベル高いと
じゃあそこで問題が生まれる
ダンマは真実であって真理であって
世の中の普通の法則であるならば
そうするとアビダンマって何の意味もないでしょうに
それより優れてる法則はあるはずがないでしょうに
存在のありのままの姿
真実の状態がダンマであるならば
アビダンマっていうのは存在するはずがないんです
それはまあなんか困った問題で
で それどういう それでどういう風な解釈になるかというと
ダンマはこのお釈迦様の普通の教えとして取るんです
その場合は お釈迦様が人々にこの対話的にお話していたのです
普通の人間に出会って
その人々にただ喋るんですね
ですから それはただの教えという意味です
そうするとどうなるかというと
この個人差が見えてくるんですね
教えの中で で 人々のこの個人個人的な持っている悩みは違うし
女性の悩みと男性の悩みがそれぞれ違うし
当時の王様の悩みと普通の国民の悩みっていうのはまたそれぞれ違うし
金持ちの人の悩みとお金全くなく苦しんでいる人の悩みまた違っちゃうし
ですから そのその人々の性格
その人々の要求に応じて
その個人が理解できるようにお釈迦様は喋るんですね
お話するんですね それは普通の我々ダンマ
教えと言うんです そこでよく我々はこの経典で見つかるのは
アーナンダ尊者によく喋って
アーナンダよ これはこういうこういうものだ
これはこういうこういうものだと言って
あるいは比丘らよ これはこういうこういうです
こういうこういうことですよと
もし あの お釈迦様の最期の弟子であったこのアナータピンディカですか
あのディッコドクコジなんとかという人なんですけど
その人に喋る場合はアナータピンディカ
これはこういうこういうものですって言うんですね
ですから あの 王様呼んで喋るでは
マハーラージャ 王様 これはこういうものですと
そこでこの人の名前挙げて
その人に喋ってるんですね
ですから 我々には今もすごく親近感というか
読みやすく この生きている人間が
その姿 その環境 その背景見えてくるんですね
ですから ちょっとわからない場合は
ちょっとしたこのストーリー読んでみると
例えば何でお釈迦様はこの場合はこういうことをおっしゃったんですか
やっぱりその場合はその人はこういうふうに困っていたんだと
だからこういうことを教えたんだというストーリーもつけているんですね
それはお釈迦様の普通の教え
それはわかりやすい 我々ごく一般的な人間に誰にでも理解できる
で それ探ってみると お釈迦様の教えを自分の性格に合っている
自分によく理解しやすい教え
いつでも見つかるんです
だから経典たくさんありますけど
我々ずっと読んでいくと
もうわからないところいっぱいあるし
つまらないと感じるもの出てくるし
その中でいきなり あ これだったらよくわかりますと
自分の性格にぴったしですというふうな
あの お釈迦様の言葉というのはもう出てくるんです
で そういうのはダンマであって
そこでお釈迦様は四十五年間教えた教えをまとめて
結局何をお話ししましたかと
学問的にこのエッセンスだけ
同じことをいろんなところでいろんな風に喋りますから
そのエッセンスだけ取ってみると
それにアビダンマと言うんです
いわゆるお釈迦様の教えの基本的な論理という意味でアビダンマと言うんです
ということは アビダンマっていうのは
お釈迦様がおっしゃったすべての教えのまとめみたいなものなんですね
だいたいそれぐらいの意味でアビダンマと言うんです
それで問題は それはあくまでもこの学問的な努力の結果みたいんですね
で お釈迦様の弟子たちももうかなりもう学者ばっかし
もう学者の数が多かったんですね
特にこの有名なサーリプッタ尊者ですか
もう抜群の知識の持ち主でも
お釈迦様にもよく褒められるんですね
智慧の素晴らしさに で
そういうお坊さんたちが
まあこの昔の直弟子たちがまあ一応何を教えたかと
こうやっぱり分析して
この分類したりしてカテゴリーにするんですね
だいたいこのサーリプッタ尊者も経に入ってますし
経典の中で その中でよく見えることは
お釈迦様はまあただただその時その人に合わせてしゃべるもの内容をやっぱりきちんとこの分析して
いろんなカテゴリーに分類してて
きちんとしゃべるんですね
その方がこの勉強する人にとっては勉強しやすいんです
ですから お釈迦様はいつでもこのよくサーリプッタ尊者に聞きなさいと
よくそこに行かすんですね
お釈迦様はその人のその時の悩みを解決してあげて
修行方法やら悟りの道とか
それを教える それ修業の人とか
その人にそれなりのことを教える
きめ細かくきちんと知りたければ
まあ整理しているサーリプッタ尊者のところに行きなさいというふうな感じの生き方でしたが
で あの それでアビダンマで個人の名前は全然出てこない
場所の名前も当然ながら出てこない
ただ論理の本だけなんです
それからもう一つ問題があって
まあそうなるとアビダンマはお釈迦様がおっしゃったものですかと
疑問が出てくるんです
なぜそんな疑問が出てくるかというと
特に上座仏教の世界 この初期仏教の世界では
とにかく釈尊の言葉は大事であって
それはもう第一番目の権威を持ってる言葉で
弟子たちの言葉っていうのは
釈尊の言葉に合うならば信じるのであって
注釈の言葉であろうとも
それはもう釈尊の元々の教えに合うならば信じるのであって
釈尊の方がもう教えこそ真理として認める宗派なんですね
あっちこっちいろんな人が自分勝手にいろんな哲学を作ったっても
そんなに大事に重点を置かないんですね
その新しい人が開発した哲学があるならば
その哲学はお釈迦様の教えにぴったり合うならば
それも勉強しようとするんだけど
だからといって その後から開発した哲学を素晴らしいんだ
これこそやというふうなことは言わない
いわゆる根拠は釈尊になければいけませんという
考え方なんですね そうすると
アビダンマはいろんなお釈迦様がおっしゃった全ての教えのまとめかもしれませんだけど
そうするとお釈迦様はそんなことをまとめませんだから
当然お釈迦様は毎日いろんなところで説法して歩き回っちゃうし
じゃあこれから仏教というもう学問を作ろうとか
仏教という宗教を作ろうとか
そんなことはもう全くしませんだから
そんな暇あるならば もう一人二人ぐらいに悟りの道を教えますから
だから亡くなる瞬間 その時でも最後の弟子に指導したんですね
悟るために このスバッダというお坊さんなんですけど
で 最後に悟ったお釈迦様生きてる間では最後に悟って悟り開いた人
お坊さんとして記録されてますけど
その瞬間まで人にものを教えるんですね
だからお釈迦様はこのもう亡くなるということで
もう体が倒れて横になっていて
もう動かないんですね
どうせもうその後ですぐ亡くなりますから
もうもう大変な状態でしょうね
もう体はもう全然動けない
その時もその 最後の弟子になろうと思った人がもう走ってきて
で 私もお釈迦様に会いたいんだと
そしたらアーナンダ尊者がもうちょっとダメですと
もう人と喋る時ではないんだと
やめなさいと もうもうそろそろお釈迦様もうそれで寿命ですと
誰でも人が死にかけていると言っても
何か教えてちょうだいというバカがいませんだけどね
でもその人はまたもう一事アーナンダ尊者と
もうそう言ったっても
お釈迦様が亡くなる前に
私もやっぱり自分の悩みを解決してほしいんだだと思った
お釈迦様はやっぱりその話を聞いて
もう何ですかと 言ったらアーナンダ尊者がまあまあ人が来て
今の時間にも何か説法を聞きたがっているんだと
通してくださいと 言って
その人の質問にちゃんと答えて
その人を悟るの道をして
その人悟りましたから
ですから お釈迦様はそういう性格でしたから
こんな学問的なテキスト書こうとかね
そんな馬鹿げたことは絶対しないということもわかるんですね
そうすると仏説でなくなっちゃうんですね
アビダンマが その疑問はテーラワーダの世界にはあったんです
仏説でないと思ったら
もうなかなか まあどうかなと
みんなまあちょっと心配なんですね
それでこの注釈書を あのもう四世紀あたりでパーリ語に翻訳しましたけど
やっぱりもう紀元前の時代からスリランカでこの仏教が伝わって以来
スリランカで膨大な注釈あったんですね
経典の それは膨大な量を縮んで
もう小さないくつかのテキストになったんです
それでももうかなり量多いんだけど
それは今パーリ語にあるテキストで
世界中で上座仏教の注釈書といえばそのテキストになってるんです
その注釈書の中でも やっぱりその問題はもうもうやっぱり何とかしなくちゃいけないんだから
その問題扱うんですね
ある人々はアビダンマは仏説ではないと言うんだと
なぜならば この経典だったら
過去のごとく私は聞きました
お釈迦様は祇園精舎に住んでる時は
なんとか何とか人に会って
なんとか何とか人にどういう場でこういうことを言ったという風に
このちゃんと歴史があってあるんですね
アビダンマではそんなこと何にもないんです
いきなりもう心流始まるんです
心は何ですかとかね いきなり始まる
だからこの皆様のテキストになってる本はいくらかわかる可能性あるんだけど
アビダンマの本当の本っていうのはもう全然わからないんで
いきなりもうなんだこれと思うほどのもう
いきなりもう説明に入っちゃうんだと
ですから この仏説ではないだろうという感じもあったんですね
そこでもブッダゴーサ長老がまた伝説であった考え方をこう言うんですね
やっぱりアビダンマは仏説ですと
それを誰に教えたかというと
お釈迦様の実の母親 生みの母
一週間で亡くなったんですね
亡くなって天国に生まれ変わったということであって
でお釈迦様は悟りを得られて六年目で
このトスス天ですね そのトスス天に行って
そこで自分の母親にと他の神々にこの仏教の論理を教えたんだと
そこで一応欠けてる部分をブッダゴーサ長老が補ってしまっちゃうんですね
でもブッダゴーサ長老自分勝手に補ったって結局それは答えにならないんですね
なぜならば 経典というのはすごい古いんだから
アビダンマテキストも古いことは古いんだから
で 一応テーラワーダ世界ではアビダンマはお釈迦様が自分の実の母親にトスス天で教えた教えですよと言ってるんです
そこで問題は まあ僕は何でも疑うんだから
そこでお釈迦様はどこか天国に行って神々に言ったことは
我々はどうやって知ってるんですかということなんですね
これ人間に喋ったなら
その人に聞けば分かりますけど
で そこでまたストーリーが続くんですね
お釈迦様の食事をサーリプッタ尊者が天国まで持っていくんだと
天国に至っても天国の時間長いんだから
天国の神々にはちょっとした二時間
三時間お話したかもしれませんだけど
それは人間の時間で三ヶ月とかになってたわけですね
だから人間の当然三ヶ月間という
やっぱりもう一日一食でも食べないと
ですから まあええでもサーリプッタ尊者がこの食事を持っていったんだと
持っていったところで
今までの喋ったことをお釈迦様はサーリプッタ尊者に教えたんだと
サーリプッタ尊者がお坊さんたちに教えたんだと
ということになってるんですね
ストーリーは それ注釈書のストーリーで
それは私はもうこう考えるんですね
結局はこれサーリプッタ尊者の教えではないかと
我々人間から見れば サーリプッタ尊者の弟子たちの伝統の中でどんどん出来上がった教えっていうことは事実ではないかというふうに思ってるんですね
それには これ学問的な考え方で
それにはそれなりの証拠がありまして
このアビダンマの元になったと思われる経典があるんです
この中部経典と長部経典にいくつか入ってるんです
それは全部仏教 お釈迦様のお経ではなくて
サーリプッタ尊者のお経なんです
サーリプッタ尊者は比丘たちを集めてこういうふうに教えたと
ちゃんとしたお経ですけど
ですから 結局こういうサーリプッタ尊者の学派という風にはちょっとおかしいんだけど
その弟子たちの伝統の中で
こういうきめ細かく論理
真理を分析して理解しましょうという伝統が広げた可能性はあるんです
で 今日から勉強するのはそういうアビダンマではないんです
で そのアビダンマは難しいんだから
このアビダンマを勉強する前に
アビダンマでどういう言葉使いますかと
いわゆるイントロダクションですね
紹介 いわゆる項目だけ
こういうこういう項目
これアビダンマに入ってるんだというとこだけなんです
このテキストはそういうテキストなんです
アビダンマにはどういう項目が入ってるんですかと
ですから アビダンマにはならないんです
でも そのテキストを書いたお坊さんも
もう大変なお坊さんだなと思いますけど
このああいうアビダンマテキストからよくもこういう風に本作ったんだから
こんな小さいテキストなんです
この今のこれほんとは大きいんだけど
これ注釈書入ってるんです
本当はこんな小さな本なんです
項目だけですから それまとめたのアヌルッダというお坊さんなんですね
何世紀かとははっきりしてないんですね
これはまあ インドのお坊さんだとも思ってるし
このビルマではこれはスリランカのお坊さんだと言ってるし
どっちだろう これははっきりわからないんです
じゃあ今日はもう一つ言葉を二つ勉強してみましょう
お釈迦様の教えはそれで二つに分けます
一つはボハーラデーサナ
ボハーラデーサナ もう一つはパラミッタデーサナ
今からの設楽さん ウォーハーデーサナ
パラマッタデーサナという二つに分けられます
あの前のことと同じこと
別にただ言葉二つ紹介するだけ
ウォーハーデーサナっていうのは practical teaching という意味で
英語で言えばあの practical
まあ実践的な まあ人々にまあ実践的に実際に実践的に教える教えであると
それはダンマになるんですね
法になるんですね なんかパーリ語っていうのは結構文字がいっぱい入って長くなっちゃいますけど
パラマッタデーサナっていうのは真理だけを教える教え
真理の教え 真理のみ それはアビダンマになっちゃうんです
で あの まあこれからアビダンマの説明に入りますが
これからの教義っていうのは
この教えはずーっとつなげてるんです
まあ一つある ある考え方に沿って説明しているものだから
この まあずっと聞いていないと何も訳も分からなくなっちゃうんです
ちゃんと聞いてるとよく理解できるんです
これは難しい難しいって言うんだけど
そんなに難しいと思ったら困るんです
ただ聞いているかないかというぐらいの差なんです
例えば数学には才能ない人とかね
もう化学に才能ない人とかね
そういう音楽に才能ない人とかはいるんですけど
いくら頑張ってもダメですと
仏教ではそういう問題ないんです
決してないんです それはすごく
この あの人には仏教の才能ないとかね
それおかしいことなんです
人には心があって その心にいろいろ状態があって
その状態の理解だから
それができないというならおかしいでしょうに
それ自分の心の状態を理解できないというならば
もうよっぽどの あの 知恵の
何て言いますか 障害持ってる人なんですね
知識障害 ですから 知識障害者でない限りはもう理解できるんです
例えば あんた怒ってるよということで理解できませんと
いう人がいないでしょう
今あんた悩んでるんではないかとかね
今悲しがってるんではないかと
そういう自分の存在 自分の勉強だから
それはできないはずがないんです
ですから 仏教ではこの難しいということはあんまり使わない方がいいんです
よく聞くとわかるんです
それは自分の心の勉強であって
自分の勉強であって 自分が自分を勉強すること
ですから 難しいと言ったっても難しくないんです
ただ本気で聞いているか
いい加減に聞いているかということで
もう違うんですね いい加減に聞いているとわからない
本当に本気で聞いているとわかる
そういうことで 決して難しいと初めからもう思う必要もない
だから やっぱりすごい簡単単純だというふうに思っちゃったら
また困る 真剣に聞かなくちゃいけない
それからこの ずっと続けていかなくちゃいけない
で 普通の私の他の法話会とかね
勉強会っていうのは まあ来ても来なくても
たまたま来てもまあどっちでもいいんです
その日でその言ってることで理解できます
で そこでこの場合は まあ例えば一つ二つ抜けちゃったら
もう抜けたことになっちゃうんで
で かなり苦労しないと
もう 何て言いますか つなげなくなっちゃうんですね
まあそれだけちょっとしたトラブルなんですけど
ですから僕はあんまりもこのこういうアビダンマ勉強っていうのはもうあんまりやりたくなかったんですね
あるいは皆様にきちんと参加できるということはもう保証できませんから
それぞれ何が起こるか分からないし
忙しくなるか分からないし
ですからもう学校みたいにね
きちんと来られるということはないし
そうするとなんかまあ私の努力は無駄になってしまうし
誰にも分からなくなっちゃうんです
だから一部は毎日人が来るかもしれませんだけど
みんなどこかどこかで一つ二つ抜けてると
誰も分からなくなってしまうんですね
まあそこら辺ちょっと気をつけていただければ
まあ簡単に理解できると思います
それからこのアビダンマテキストっていうのは
ミャンマーやらスリランカやら
まあ大体子供たちに教えるテキストなんです
で あの まあ大人の勉強する本じゃないんです
大人が勉強する本ではないんです
ですから まあそんなに難しいとね
思う必要はないんです
で 子供の時はこういうのを全部暗記して覚えて終わっちゃうんです
まあ私ももしかするともう
まあ 1ヶ月2ヶ月で全部終わってしまったんだから
週1回ぐらいの講義で
そんなに そんなもんです
だからそれ難しい難しいとね
まあ思う必要ない で 暗記するものも全部一発で暗記できてまっちゃったし
で それは別に暗記力がいいというわけじゃなくて
きちんと整理しているんだから
まあ暗記しやすいですね
うん さあ じゃあこれからアビダンマに入ります
で 一番アビダンマの世界に入る前に
また言葉二つ勉強するんです
この言葉とまた似ているんです
言葉二つ 一つはサンムティ
サンムティ・サッチャ
二番目はパラマッタ・サッチャ
このサンムティ・サッチャ
パラマッタ・サッチャというところで
このサッチャという言葉を皆様は知っていると思います
ドゥッカ・サッチャとか
この四聖諦の場合はよく使っている言葉なんですね
ドゥッカ・サッチャ これは真理という意味で
サッチャっていうのは真実
真理という意味なんです
あの苦・聖・諦 まあ苦諦・集諦・滅諦・道諦という
この皆様よくご存知 この四聖諦
その場合も諦と書いて
それは真理という意味なんですね
いわゆる真実 本当のところということで
そこでサンムティ・サッチャというのは何ですかと
サンムティ・サッチャっていうのは
あの これすごくいい言葉だと思いますよ
サンムティっていうのはみんなで何か決めることなんですね
じゃあ何かもうこういうふうに決めましょうと
それでもう決めら--そういうふうに決まって
決まってるんだから まあそれはまあ
真実として認める まあそういう意味で使ってないんだから
結局そういう意味の言葉なんですね
サンモティ 例えばもう会議があって
みんなでいろいろディスカッションして
まあ最終的に じゃあ まあそういうことで
こういうこういうふうに決めましょうと
いうふうに決めてしまう
人が何か犯罪を起こしたと言ったならば
もうちゃんと裁判で それはもう調べるんですね
いろいろ証拠とかいろんなものがあったりして
そこでもう最終的な判決で
まあその人は有罪だと決まったら
その人がやっぱり犯人になってしまっちゃうんですね
そこでもうみんなで決めたんだから
そうなる もし証拠をちょっとした何か
あの 噛み合わないところがあったら
そこでその人は無罪になる
本当にその人はその犯罪を起こしたかもしれませんだけど
その場合は無罪になってしまう
それでどうしようもなく決まってるんだから
その人は無罪だ もう普通に自由にしてあげなさいということになってしまったんです
それもどうしようもないことで
みんなでそう決められた
決めたんだから そこで仏教での世の中で我々が考えたり
喋ったり いろんな思想したりして作ってる全ての知識はサンモティ・サッチャであると
それはまあただそう決まってるんだと
一切の知識 今まで皆様方いろんなことを勉強なさってきたと思いますけど
そういうのは仏教から見ればサンモティ・サッチャ
例えばいろんな液体があります
その液体にこれは硫酸だとか
これはもう何とか何とかとか
決まっ--き--みんなで決まってるでしょう
ある科学者が何とか研究して
これはこういうこういうことで
こういうふうなものだよと言ったら
ああそうで それから我々はもうそういうふうに考えてしまっちゃう
えーと まあわかりやすく
わかりやすく例で言うならば
例えば まあ人はもう一日三食食べ
食べなくちゃいけないんだと
それはただ決まってるんだから
そういう真理になってるんですね
やっぱり人間は三食食べなくちゃいけないんだ
だから一食はこれぐらいカロリーを摂らなくちゃいけないんだとか
ただの決まりなんですね
一日何キロカロリーを摂らなくちゃいけないかと
お医者さんたちがすごい科学的に研究して決まっ--発見すると思ってるのが
それただの決まりだけなんです
それぐらいちょっとカロリーが少なくなっても
人間別に病気になって倒れて死ぬわけでもないし
もうちょっとカロリー余分に取ったって
取ったにしたっても 別にどうったことないし
どんな人もきちんと計算して
一日何千カロリーか僕わかりませんだけど
まあそれぐらいのカロリーを食べてるんだかというと
それ全くないし そういう研究をして
あの あの 発見したお医者さんたちも
もういい加減食べてはいるんですね
まあこれ食べてこれとこれで
あ 朝ごはんのカロリー
カロリーは OK だと これで OK だと今日は決まられませんね
でもやっぱりまあ一日これぐらいカロリーを摂らなくちゃいけないというふうに
まあ大雑把に決まってるんです
俺たちは三食食べる場合もあるし
二食食べる場合もあるし
一日一食で終わる場合もあるし
一日で五回食べる場合もあるんです
だからって別にどうかしたということでもないんです
でも一日これぐらいの
例えばもう四千カロリー
どれぐらいですかね 一日に
二千？五百？二千四 例えば一日二千四百カロリーきちんと摂らなくちゃいけないと
言って これ二千四百 二百になったら
あるいは二千カロリーになったところでもう大変な結果になったならば
まあちょっと考えた方がいいんですね
一応その数字はまあいろんなところから考えて計算して
まあ大雑把に決めてるだけで
それからそれもやとヨーロッパ人の体を計算している数字かもしれませんし
アジア人はまあ その そんなカロリー取っちゃったらもう大変ダメなんですね
ですから これはまあ それもうサンモティですね
みんなで決まってることです
例えばどんな色の服を着ますかとかね
どんな形の もう例えば大体女性の服と男性の服って
もうもし男性が女性が来る--着る服を着てこっちに来たならば
みんなおかしいんだ あんたおかしいんではなく
変ではないかと と言うでしょ
それはただの決まりだけなんですね
女性は男性の服を着たっても
男性は女性の服でもどうでもいいことなんですね
でも決まりだから それは世の中の正しい生き方だと我々は決まってるんです
そう思ってるんです 女性はこうするべき
男性はこうするべきだと
ただの決まり 別に徹底した真理
いいわけあるじゃないんです
女性は例えばスカートやら着物やらそういうものを着なくちゃいけないとかね
という決まりはないんだけど
一般的にはそんなもんだと決まってるだけ
全てそういうものなんです
世の中 例えば日本の国土というんですか
どれぐらい面積ありますか
それぐらいは日本だと
海からこれぐらいの二百海里ですか
は日本の領土だとかね
ただの決まりなんですね
で こちらは韓国だ こちらは北朝鮮だ
こちらはソ連だ こちらは中国だとかね
そういうのは人間の決まりで
もうそれ以上何もない
でも だからってそれは嘘ですかと言うと
嘘でもないんです ちゃんと日本の領土は
それは日本の領土で ちょっと自分に取ろうと思っちゃったら
もう香港人やら台湾人に怒られるとかね
欲張って増やそうと思ったらそうなったりするし
ですから やっぱり一般的にはまあそれは真実なんですね
例えばこの一番面白いことは
この人のものを取ってはいけないよ
それは泥棒であって 盗み事であって
この犯罪なんですね それを本当にそうですかね
人のものを取ったら犯罪ですかね
なぜそうなるんですかというと
これは鈴木さんの機械だともう勝手に決まってるんですね
そうすると 私が取って行っちゃったら
もう何やってるんですかと
私を私が怒られるかもしれませんね
それは人のものだと決まってるんだから
取ったら盗みになるんであって
それは人のものじゃないんだと
と決まってしまえば もう犯罪にはならなくなっちゃうんですね
全部決まりなんです それぐらい理解すると
結構アビダンマ的な智慧が生まれるんです
全てやっぱり あ そう決まってるものだけですか
別にその中で徹底した真理あるわけじゃないんです
盗むなっていうことも同じことで
もうこういうこういう服着なくちゃいけないとかね
いろいろのすべてのもの
学校にはちゃんと遅刻しないでちゃんと行かなくちゃいけないんだとかね
それは決まりだから 遅刻したらそれはもう間違いを起こしましたと
ああだこうだとか 親にまで電話かけてくる
学校から もし親がそういう風に遅刻してはいけないと誰が決めたんですか？と言ったら
それは学校の決まり 学校の皆さん勝手にやってください
私は関係ないと言っちゃったら
本当はどうするんですか
もしそういういい加減なことも必要すればできるし
例えば国の法律でもうこうしてはいけません
こうしてはいけませんと
あるところで私たちはもう守ってはいますけど
じゃあもう勝手に向こうが決めてるんだから
まあ勝手にやってくれ
私はもうもうそれには同意しませんと言えば
言っちゃえば まあそれでもう大変なことになりますよね
それでこういうことなんです
まず言いたいのは 我々は真実だと思っているものは
一切は人間の世界で決まってるものだけなんです
それに徹底して真実性とか真理とか論理的な根拠とかはない
だからといって嘘わけでもない
なぜならばみんなでそう決まってるんだから
だから我々はそれに従わなくちゃいけない
だからといって 例えば学校でちゃんと遅刻しないでも早く学校に行きなさいというのは決まりで
はい わかりましたと それを守ればいいんです
別に なんでちゃんと時間に行かなくちゃいけないんです
1時間遅れたらもう別にいいんじゃないですかと
1時間目の授業 私は嫌いですから
もうもっとその時間寝たいとかね
といっても それは個人の決まりで
みんなの決まりじゃないんですね
だからどうせみんなの決まりは強いし
個人の決まりにはそれほど説得力はないんですね
ただそれだけのこと 大体世の中の人間っていうのはそこで非常困ってるんですね
そういうことは何のこともないと
で もっと他の例を申し上げます
バラの花っていうのは綺麗なもので
それはまあ家の中を綺麗にするために使うものだとかね
人を例えば病院なんかにお見舞いに行く時は持っていって相手を喜ばせるものだと
人間は花を見て大変喜ぶんだというのは真実ですかね
それはそう決まってるだけなんです
真実とか何でもないんです
赤の赤いバラはこういう意味だと
黄色いバラはこういう意味だと
白いバラはこういう意味だと
何の根拠もなく勝手に決まってるものだから
それぐらいのことなんです
で バラの花っていうのは見て喜ぶものだというならば
別にじゃあ犬にあげてみたらどうですかね
自分飼ってる猫ちゃんにあげてみたらどうですかね
はい バラの花持ってきたよとかね
全然喜んでくれませんでしょう
それは人間だけの決まり
そこで犬にとってすごい居心地のいいところっていうのは
人間にとっては決してそうではないし
タヌキにとってはすごい居心地のいいところは
人間にとっては別に居心地のいいところでもなんでもないし
そこら辺なんですね アビダンマはそこから始まるんですね
ですから この世の中で決まってる真実は
決して否定しているわけじゃないんです
決まってるんだから真実であると
それ以上は何もないんだと
いうところから始まるんです
それは英語ではConventional truthと言うんです
ちょっと難しい言葉ですけど
あ 日本語の言葉で世俗諦でしたっけ？世俗諦というんです
こっちも書いておきたいな
私の発音でソとゾの全然区別はないんだから
大変理解に苦しいと思いますけど
まあ世俗諦はこういう感じなんです
こう世俗で これソクですか？ゾクですか？属
このぜぞく せぞく そうすると全部濁ってしまいます
[笑い]これローマ字で書いておくと読めるんだけど
この世俗体というと 我々なんとなく
ちょっとしたこの固定観念で何か思うかもしれません
違う感じがするかもしれません
だいたい犬猫の世界の決まりも世俗体なんです
虫たちが決まってるものも世俗体なんです
人間が決まってるものも世俗体なんです
人間超えてる神々 梵天とかいろいろ存在がいると
あると聞いたことがありますけど
見たことがないんだけど
まあやっぱり あの その世界で天国でもいいんだけど
決まってるものは世俗体である
全部決まりですね 例えばミツバチの世界では
もうそれなりの決まりがあります
それを破っちゃったらダメなんですね
ミツバチは蜜を代わりにご飯粒持っていっちゃったらもう困るんです
これも食べ物です やっぱりミツバチの世界ではご飯は食べ物だと決まってないんです
もし何とかして食べたら死ぬ
死なない 死ぬわけないと思います
やっぱり決まりは決まりだからしょうがないんです
ですから もうこれは人間であろうか
もう誰であろうか もう我々の世界で認識で決まってるもの
ということは 例えば太陽があって
惑星がいっぱいあって
それの一つは地球ですよと
それは人間決まってるんであって
だから必ずしも太陽があって
惑星があって その一部
一つは地球であるということ
これはちょっと言いにくいものなんです
それは人間が作った世界だからね
宇宙があって もうビッグバンがあったりして
想像して それからどんどん膨張している宇宙があって
いろいろ星団があったり
ああだこうだとかね それは人間から考えた
見た世界なんですね ですから
そういう話さえ仏教では世俗体になるんです
例えば地球は丸いということ
まあ丸いって言うんですか
もう まあ地球だからね
まあそれもある角度で見るとそうなるんであって
昔の人々は全然地球と言わなかったんだから
大地と言っていたんだから
その人々の決まりで見ると
それはもう別に丸いものじゃないんですね
だから我々の威張って昔の人々は知らなかったぞとかね
我々今よく知ってるぞと言ったって嘘でしょ
あれ いまだに知らないんだから
地球本当に球状体ですか
知らないでしょうね 本当のところは
一応  ある計算やらある本やら勉強して
いろんな写真やら見て
ああやっぱり丸いんですと
というふうに思うんだけど
そういう方向を見ると丸い
丸いものであって 普通に見るともう何のことなく
もう もう一応丸くは見えますけど
まあこういう横に でも球状体には見えないんですね
ですから そういう科学的な真実的な真理だと言っているものも
仏教では世俗諦だと言っているんです
それに訳があるんです
角度が変われば この真実だと言っていたことは変化するんです
で 昔は人は病気になるのはもう悪霊ですか
そういう悪い霊が憑くんだからと思っていたんですね
そこで昔の人々はもうこの悪霊追い払いという何か儀式をやって
人が病気になったら もうそういう何かするんです
それはもう  それは治療なんです
その人はお医者さんなんです
当時の昔の世界では で
その社会では当然人が病気になったら悪霊が憑いていて
それ悪霊を追っ払うためにいろいろ呪文やら踊りやら
いろんな薬を飲ませるとか
ご飯食べさせないでおくとか
いろんなことをしていたんです
そこで人の病気を治ったり
治らなかったり 人が死んだりという三つの現象があったんですね
それで もう別にそれは真実であって
その社会でもう一人の頭の悪い人が出てきて
とんでもないんだと 人は病気になるのはこの人悪いものを食べたんだからとかね
と言っちゃったら あんた何言ってるんだよ
嘘を言うなって それ悪いものを食べたものに霊が憑いてたんだから
その人は病気になったんですよ
だからそれを体から出せば
この悪霊と一緒に出しちゃえばもう元気ですよって言っちゃうんです